thank you
um yeah i'm one of the organizers of pi
data boolean so thank you for showing up
i hope you all have a great time
and we will start the meetups again
every third wednesday probably starting
from next month so maybe see you around
there
yeah my name is daniel i work for debate
sister
and for the first time we are one of the
sponsors so if you are interested in
jobs you can go upstairs and talk to us
um yeah
so
i'm a data scientist and a couple of
like years ago i had to do some thank
you plots and i was like maybe i should
talk about it because you don't find
that much stuff on the internet
so maybe just start like really from
scratch uh like what are thank you plots
and basically thanks are just flow
charts
um where the flow has like a certain
width which stands for the amount or the
volume of of the data
um they are named after matthew thank
you who was like an engineer and did a
paper on steam engines um
and he made this like thank you plot
that you can like see an extract here
where he basically yeah you see the
distribution of heat in such a chart so
he compared the current model to some
some uh yeah idealized version of it so
he did that in like late uh 19th century
um
actually the first thank you plot is
like yeah almost 100 years earlier
from charles minard who
visualized this uh
napoleon's route to russia
um probably many of you have seen this
before like it's one i guess of the most
famous um graphics and um in this like
2d graphic you see like many many data
types so like you have location you have
like the amount you know like the width
of the the flow
um
you have temperature and time so like
you have like a lot of data types here
but this is kind of like a thank you
chart in like its most like original way
um nowadays you see it much more often
like energy flows
so i have two examples here um the
international energy agency
um shows this energy flow of the entire
planet and like when we zoom in you can
see some different like energy sources
and you have some
steps here like production and import
and export
and you can filter that by by year so
it's kind of interesting to see how that
changed over over the years
um also with eurostat like a european uh
website you can see the like kind of the
same stuff that um as before so it's
like an interactive energy balance from
all the countries of the european union
or the whole european union so you can
like filter that as well between
different years and different countries
so like if we look like a little bit
closer you can see like imports and
exports and you see those different
distributions like each color stands for
uh like one of the energy sources
so you see different steps along the
process from like production import
they have some transformation here and
in the end you have consumption
exports and some like waste in the
process so guess
that's quite like important to see you
have different steps
you have different categories and like
with those flows you can see the
distribution of those categories
at a certain
moment in that in that process
so um how are they used today i guess
many of you see maybe those like voter
flow charts in elections now i found
that for a german election from last
year and five years ago
so you see the different parties color
coded with different colors and then i
guess like with the thank you chart like
what you really want to show or
highlight is the the flow so the
question is
like where does something go to like in
that case you know you see one party on
the left side which is highlighted in
red and then you see the flow of voters
you know who voted again for the same
party or who voted for different parties
um at the same time you can just like
reverse it you know and you can ask the
question where does something come from
so if you see now
the green party on the right you can see
how many voters like yeah stayed the
same and how many voters from different
parties voted now for like another party
so i guess the the
main main focus on those shots is
basically to to show you where does
something come from and where does
something go
yeah
you can also extend it so here you see
like a thank you plot from um the
economist
for the british election like for a
couple of years so you can like extend e
d y axes for multiple years as you can
see here um
and um yeah make it much more uh yeah
interesting for for more than uh like
just one year
so um yeah just just to get like an idea
like what you um yeah what thank you
plots are about so basically you have a
flow of different categories um at two
or more steps you know with the german
election we have two years uh that we
compare and with the british one we had
four for the energy charts also we have
different steps on the on the process
and the important part is like the the
flow of the data so you have like a
redistribution of those categories
usually going from the left side to the
right side
um yeah and those distributions you can
basically just calculate like they are
kind of implied because you can just sum
up all the flows
of one category at the step
yeah and then kind of important to
highlight like the width of the line
should always represent some volume or
mount like if you see some really bad
examples that doesn't really match up
then it's kind of difficult to
understand and maybe yeah
maybe like misleading in in some way
so the idea of my talk was just like how
to do that with python right like i had
a customer we had some data and i wanted
to do some thank you plots so i just
tried some some libraries and for this
talk now i just you know started from
scratch see how easy is it is it with
different libraries to get started to to
make such a thank you plot
so
first i wanted to get some data from the
deutsche bahn like how you know which
energy do they use but i could only find
the distribution of the data but not the
flow so it was like yeah too bad
um so i looked further and i found the
um like some census data from berlin
where you can see you know different
years here
you see some kind of you know beginning
of the year how many people live in
berlin how many people are born how many
people died
you see how many people are immigrating
and emigrating
and then you have like a total um of the
year
and then like a total number of people
living in berlin at the end of the year
what's kind of interesting what maybe
you don't see in the beginning the
numbers don't match up so i was kind of
confused because you know you i
recalculated the lines and was like that
does look kind of weird so there is some
kind of error in here which is not that
small
and i was trying to find out where this
happens and i guess it's just different
like governmental agencies calculate the
numbers differently so you just have
like an error in here which is um yeah
seems like people are disappearing in
berlin so um yeah i i tried to yeah just
took those numbers here you can see this
error of like almost like four and a
half thousand people which were just
like disappearing
um but i just took those numbers from
the sheet
um
gave them some names and um yeah this is
kind of like how to get started
so first library obvious choice um i
guess everybody knows uh like from num
focus like sponsor project and um
they have like just a thank you class
which you can import
and many examples so i started you know
importing the class um initializing the
the class and adding a flow and that was
the result it was like yeah
what happened here you know
um so you go through the documentation
um
and i found this like magic scale
keyword so because the numbers are quite
high mudpop lips kind of expect numbers
around like 1 to 10 i guess so larger
numbers small scale like
it looks better but still it's kind of
not what i'm supposed to like wanted to
to show
so you know just going further in
documentation
orientations is kind of the key word so
with orientations you can tell mudpotlip
where does something come from and where
does something go so the zero here
stands for it comes from the left goes
to the right so i took that for the
beginning and the start
and the end of the the um
the numbers
and then with minus one and one you can
kind of tell it does it go to the top or
does it go to the bottom so
you know with like just a few steps it
looks kind of okay
but yeah i guess it could be better
right so um
i found this path length attribute where
you can just say you know with the error
it goes a little bit like longer so it's
like it's easier to read you know
so
finally getting somewhere which like
looks kind of close to the original
thank you plus
um yeah like seeing those numbers right
like the scientific notation doesn't
really help me here too much so i just
wrote it like in like a small method for
um adding this like thousand separator
and
getting rid of just like scientific
notation
so you know kind of kind of getting
somewhere
and then in the end i was just like yeah
just removing the color because i don't
need it like blue doesn't show me
anything here and adding a title
so i guess you know
kind of what i wanted to do easy but
like you have to do all the steps
explicitly uh on your own
so yeah thank you plots i guess get kind
of interesting when you add more steps
so it's like how how easy is it to like
add another year so i edited like 2019
data as well so you can see here like
almost 3 000 people disappeared in
berlin wherever they went um so just
like doing the same as before
um and i guess the like the most
important part here is like you have one
object you just use this like add method
for adding uh data from different years
and then the second
uh the second flow you can see you have
a prior and you have a connect so you
kind of tell it where do you want to
connect the second flow to the first
so that was kind of easy and
straightforward but like a little bit
surprised how easy that was but yeah
that was kind of like you know getting
started with mudpodlip so um
it is quite original to like the
original flowchart and like the you know
the menard
chart that you have seen before
um you on the other hand have to do all
the stuff explicitly so you really have
to tell mudpop what you want to do but
at the positive side you really can tell
it what to do right
um documentation is good but it's a lot
so like you don't you know where where
to start it's just a lot but at the
other side there's a lot of
documentation
um
i had some pitfalls with the scale and
the format arguments but i guess like
matpot lip is so well used that you can
find all the stuff on stack overflow and
really can can do something but you know
tooltips or something like that you know
it will just take a lot of programming
and yeah you know what i'm talking about
so i looked at gitlab for like some you
know small projects how to get started
and i found pythankey which is i guess
just like a single girl uh doing that um
so i
imported it and you can see now here um
pandas so you know that's great just get
data into a data frame so that like
that's much much easier to handle
so i created like a data frame from the
2020 data just with like you know the
the actual flows
where's the start where's the target
what's the amount of of people
and then it's just like magic you know
you tell it where's left where's right
um what's the value and like that's
basically it so
there was quite a cool to get started at
the other
side like documentation was not that
good
um
some stuff didn't really work and you
like not you can't really add more than
one step so
um
i guess it's good if like the chart that
you just saw is what you want to have
but you can't really go further than
that so it's a lot of try and error you
don't really have documentation
some stuff is like missing
but i guess it's good to get started
like simple plot and um i get data frame
so i found another one quite similar a p
thank you
um so i installed that
imported it used it just you know use
the same data frame as before
um works
in a way right
um at the same time you can't really you
know change a lot but
i think it looks a little bit better at
the other side
i don't know why they have the lines
like you know coming from down left to
top right
i guess could be better but it's all
like magically calculated somehow
um
so
just doing the same stuff as before um
adding the 2019 data
just have the data frame so like with
that library you can add multiple steps
which makes it i guess like much more
usable
um
easy to get started like not that easy
to like really use right it's a little
bit crowded
uh on top hard to to read but at the
other side
not a lot of code right it's just
give it a data frame and
the rest is like magic
so also works with data frames you can
have multiple steps now
um it is a short but helpful
documentation
there are like some really smart ideas
here so like there's one argument where
you can like highlight some notes so i
guess when you really want to say you
know that's what i care about that's
kind of easy
but i haven't found like an easy way to
customize where the notes are positioned
you know and then it's kind of you know
crowded on top and
difficult to read
so getting more like in sponsored
projects and like much more you know um
yeah
bigger libraries so whole of youth is uh
sponsored by anaconda
um and it uses the bookie backend which
you know many people probably know
immediately makes it more interactive
so
it's just part of the main holoview
library
so just trying to get the example
running
just few lines of code works immediately
so that was kind of fine
um yeah so i used the 2020 data that we
used before you know just to like data
frame with 2020 data
put it in
works you know and it's kind of
interactive so you see
stuff here which is you know really nice
um so i would say like that's much
better much easier than the stuff before
um yeah and the notes are kind of
yeah make sense right
so
let's add another level right like we
have the two-step data like the the data
frame with 2019 and 2020 just putting it
in
um
yeah just works you know that makes it
kind of easy
um
coloring the
the like flows and the notes made it
it's not that easy like you could tell
it you know which
which um attribute to use and then you
have to give it a color map
um
yeah we're just like yeah i don't want
to like you know spend an hour now just
doing a color map
maybe there's some easy part but i guess
like hold of you also um
on like stack overflow or something you
probably can find some some hacks to to
do that
so like all of you like with data frames
super easy to get started you have all
the like interactivity with the bookie
back end like your tool tips and that
stuff
um you have a really short user guide uh
with only a few examples so i guess
would be nice if there would be just
more to get you started and makes it
easier to you know
see how it's done um
and i could really find a way to change
the note position so i guess that's also
like something you know when you have
all those notes you know on top
could be better i guess in a way
but maybe it's possible you know like
probably some people hacked it in a
smart way so
um yeah last library that i uh that i
checked was plotly which i use at work
right now so
um i i don't know how free it is i guess
you can use it free but then for
companies you have to to pay for it um
but i guess bloody also has like a lot
of stuff so
um just import it portly um you see code
gets a little bit you know more um so i
was just trying to get the the example
running so
you import this like thank you class
here
and here we have some like we define
nodes first and then we define the flows
so this is just the example data with
some like random labels and random
links
and values so
this is basically how how the plotly
example like uh yeah looks like and you
know with the open source libraries
before you install something you try to
get the example running it doesn't work
i was like yeah just you know start
simple in the beginning
so
yeah i changed the data a little bit now
so um
it is basically the same as before i
just added colors here
um so you see this data frame now and we
have just like see like the the c um
value here which is just colors of the
different flow so it was like yeah let's
make it more like readable and then like
yeah prettier so it's basically the same
data frame as before two years
uh with the color
column
so
yeah i found this like hack for plotly
to use data frames for thank you charts
so it's just like making a unique series
of all the notes in source or target
so we can use those like indices for all
the other um
yeah attributes that we need
so what you see now we we define like
the notes you know just the list as you
see before
we have uh like the note indices
um and then we have links you know we
add the source to the target with the
value
and
looks like that so i like that way more
you also have tooltips again like it's
easy to add a title um yeah you have
yeah all the stuff and it looks kind of
pretty without changing too much it was
kind of surprising
yeah at the same time you know
it's not perfect like it's all crowded
here you can't really spot the
difference and we're like where does
something come from where does something
go so was like yeah how how can we
improve that
um
so what's kind of cool but difficult you
can really change a note position now in
an easy way but it's kind of complicated
so you can define like x and y values
for all the notes so it took me like a
lot of try and error to like get it
where i wanted it to be so this is how
it looks you just like give it kind of a
position x and y
um i also gave the note some color
so yeah it took me probably half an hour
to just like you know change like a
point three to a point two and see how
like how it looks like
but um
yeah that's what i did i i found this
padding or like pad attribute as well
which is just like giving some space
between the notes
um i give the link the the color
and um yeah
this is basically
how it looks like we're just like yeah
we have simple colors we kind of know
uh yeah we have tooltips and the notes
are kind of where they are supposed to
be like for me this is kind of what a
thinking should look like and would
probably in in that case it was the
easiest at the same time
it's a lot of lines of code just for
like a simple thank you chart right but
i guess it's not that easy to to
automate all that
yeah so um yeah plotley was very
adjustable interactive
you can move the nodes so that was the
only library that i found easy to really
change it
even though it's kind of like tricky to
do
you have many examples which is great
um yeah and um
yeah difficult to arrange but you know
you have all the power which is which is
great
so like just some some some takeaways in
like regards to thank you plot so um i
guess it's quite important to know what
do you want to show right like are you
interested in distributions then you
should probably take like a bar chart or
like maybe a pie chart if you don't have
too many uh categories but if you're
interested in flows you know
you have to fit is your data right for
flows you know if you only have the
distribution data that's not enough to
create a thank you
you really need the data for it which
can be tricky to get
and
in my experience it only looks good if
you don't have too many categories
um like i will show you some like good
and bad examples now uh so you can like
i guess you see quite quickly what i
mean
um at the same time like make sure it's
worth the effort like it takes time it's
not that easy to do
um so getting your data in the correct
format and then like customizing the
plot over and over until you are at a
point where you're like this looks great
um
yeah it is tricky
um and then in the end as well like
think about colors right like all the
default colors are quite yeah heavy um
so if you find some good examples that's
like yeah easy to to guide you
so just some examples you know we've
seen that before this is something i
kind of like it's easy
um
i also like like economists one like
they they have really good like color
codes as well like old stuff and like
good good uh newspapers they usually
have good people like the data
visualization skills and um
yeah always good to to see those
examples
um i found this example which i really
like which is like petroleum in like
where you know something comes from what
imports
um i think that's kind of like you know
easy like not too many colors uh like
just one one scale and kind of you know
easy to read so i really like that
example
and then uh maybe just my phone which
are kind of like bad which is like
yeah yeah kind of uh yeah you know what
i mean too many categories weird colors
you don't really see anything apart from
like a few countries that stand out
um
and then i found that one which is
probably the worst i've seen in a really
long time
and somebody completely yeah
yeah
used it incorrectly so i guess like the
the colorful errors like just here on
the bottom are kind of the ones going
out of the blue arrow so they're even
like on the wrong position and yeah the
the width just doesn't make any sense at
all
um yeah
so yeah i just like put the links um
here on the bottom you see the libraries
on top you see some like further further
reading um
[Music]
and like you can get the slides here um
that's maybe the easiest to to get
started like get get the links um
and yeah i hope you learned something
and
i'm open for your questions
thanks a lot daniel for his presentation
on thank you but yeah
i think yeah i already went through and
it has been quite painful for me for a
painful experience for this thank you
blood
we have some
some questions
yeah
one question
about how do you present the sun can you
present the sun keep plots from from
right to left for some language we are
reading from right to left
what the middle part
uh can you can you present some sanki
plot like does the option exist to
present
from right to left for the language you
are reading from right to left i guess
with well good question uh
i guess you could just change it around
right
like i guess mud portland yellow like i
guess it should be hackable in that way
um
and i guess like four for all the other
ones we saw in the in the end you just
change around the you know the order and
then it should should work
thank you
just a hint from mike who says that on
matplotlib it can be
[Music]
usually start with the mad partly
website and it can be more complex than
diagram 2 on the map property website
and another
[Music]
from pr olivier is saying that you can
reorder the node in a sun key with the
whole of this by using
that redim
but yeah just a remark okay
thank you
if you have any question in the audience
yeah
thank you for these votings looked great
because they were like a lot of change
like some parties just like lost a lot
of lost a lot of voters
and berlin population kind of hovered
around 3.6 3.5 million and like the
differences
we were interested in we're just like
couple of thousands do you think it's
like
or is there some option to kind of break
like these 3.5 million of berlin
inhabitants we are not that interested
in to see like these little
errors like better is there some
visualization tool you know you can just
like you know
divide it you know by a few hundred or
something just make it you know steady
or just remove it completely you know if
you're not really interested in the
total population but just to change i
guess it makes sense to just remove it
because you know you're just interested
in like how many people come and how
many people go
so yeah i guess on that regard like if
it's difficult to read if you have like
one really large numbers and the others
are kind of small so maybe just removing
it if you're not interested in it
makes it
easier
okay thanks
we still have time for another question
[Music]
okay then thanks a lot daniel